[Musica]
la bellezza di cui vi voglio parlare io
invece è una bellezza che ha
condizionato radicalmente tutta la mia
vita
noi
io personalmente mi sono sempre posta
questa domanda che cos'è la bellezza
non so se voi siete riusciti a dare un
vero e proprio significato a questa
parola io
l'alba dei miei 30 anni ancora non sono
riuscita a dare un significato pieno a
questa parola però so esattamente come
questa parola abbia condizionato e
modificato tutta la mia vita
sono nata e cresciuta in un mondo dove
la bellezza ci viene presentata con dei
canoni molto ristretti dove la bellezza
prevede che una persona abbia tutte le
parti del corpo al posto giusto delle
misure giuste
viviamo in un mondo dove la bellezza ci
viene inculcata 24 ore su 24 attraverso
la televisione attraverso le sfilate di
moda attraverso le riviste cartelloni
pubblicitari ci mostrano sempre donne
bellissime donne perfette
viviamo in un mondo di bellezza
apparente dove veramente non non è
prevista l'ombra di un difetto quello
che io mi domando e vi domando io ho
visto in blu perfetta c'è basta
guardarmi per capire che io no tutto al
posto giusto
mi piacerebbe mi sono domandata quando
ci siamo incontrati
all'inizio di questa esperienza mi
sarebbe piaciuto sapere che cosa voi
abbiate pensato di me nel vedermi di
primo impatto perché purtroppo viviamo
in un mondo dove l'apparenza a volte è
il 90 per cento della percezione di una
persona
io sono qui oggi per raccontarvi la mia
storia e per farvi capire come
in realtà al di là della bellezza
apparente ci sia molto di più da
raccontare di una persona sono nata e
cresciuta con un raro tumore alla retina
che mi ha colpita all'età di soli 20
giorni in realtà già dal quinto mese di
gravidanza di mia mamma
questo tumore insomma iniziato a a
colpirmi la cosa più buffa di questa
situazione è stato che io ho imparato a
convivere con questa malattia io ho
imparato a convivere con una disabilità
che mi ha portato via quasi
completamente la vista da un occhio non
vedo nulla dall'altro vedo meno di un
decimo
ho bisogno di aiuto di sostegno nella
vita di tutti i giorni per fare anche le
più piccole cose
non potrò mai guidare lo riesco a
leggere insomma tutta una serie di
situazioni ma ho imparato a convivere
perché questa è la mia vita è una vita
in cui
si affronta una disabilità quello per
cui ho dovuto lavorare veramente tanto è
stato invece riuscire a convivere con la
mia diversità
l'essere diversa ho iniziato da piccola
a chiedermi perché i miei compagni
dell'asilo fossero diversi da me o
perché io fossi diversa da loro questo
tipo di ragionamento mi portava a volte
a chiudermi in me stessa non non avevo
tutta questa voglia di socializzare o di
mettermi in mostra o di creare delle
grandi relazioni fino a quando vivendo
un'esperienza di solo un po particolare
in cui mi sono ritrovata a dover
scegliere di buttarmi nel mondo
mi sono resa conto che in realtà non
tutte le persone non tutti i bambini nel
mio caso erano tra virgolette cattivi
quindi giudicavano prendevano in giro
soltanto per il mio aspetto la realtà
c'erano un sacco di bambini a cui il mio
aspetto non interessava e avevano solo
voglia di fare quello che fanno i
bambini di giocare di uscire di andare
al parco di divertirsi ho avuto anche
un'altra grande fortuna della mia vita
che è stata quella di avere una famiglia
e degli insegnanti che mi hanno fatto
vivere in un contesto assolutamente
paritario anzi molto intelligentemente
hanno creato delle situazioni
scolastiche in cui mi veniva ha permesso
di stare al posto che fare 10 20 ore di
sostegno fuori dalla classe era la
classe che faceva tutte le attività
didattiche
più manuali più tattivi in modo tale che
venivano coinvolti tutti i compagni in
progetti e sono io è nata la piccola
mascotte della scuola si perdevano un
sacco di ore noiosissime per fare invece
dei laboratori artistici grandiosi
abbiamo fatto anche dei progetti tra
l'altro che sono stati poi esposti in
alcune mostre e quindi diciamo che
questo atteggiamento delle persone nei
miei confronti mi ha permesso di
riuscire a comprendere che potevo creare
delle relazioni anche con gli altri dei
momenti di condivisione perché si
potevano fare determinate cose anche se
in maniera diversa però era fattibile
farle e quindi dal punto di vista
diciamo dei rapporti interpersonali ho
veramente avuto una grande una grande
fortuna
ben diverso è invece il momento in cui
ti ritrovi a casa a ragionare dice ok ho
una bella famiglia
ho tanti amici o un buon carattere
però poi ti trovi davanti allo specchio
dici sì va bene ho tutte queste cose
sono una persona fortunata però perché a
me cosa ho fatto di male nella mia vita
per meritarmi questo per avere questo
aspetto per avere questa faccia per
essere diversa me lo sono chiesto a un
miliardo di volte mi sono domandata se
mai avrei trovato nella vita una persona
che era in grado di amarmi e di
sostenermi per la persona che sono io
interiormente e non basandosi solo sul
fatto di essere diversa di avere un
aspetto diverso dagli altri e vi posso
assicurare che è una domanda che ha
fatto tanto male ha fatto tanto male ha
fatto tanto male sentirsi giudicare
sentirsi affibbiare nomignoli sentirsi
dire dalle persone ma io fossi in te non
uscire di casa ma che vergogna perché
purtroppo questa è la realtà dei fatti e
quindi dovevo trovare un modo nella mia
testa
per me stessa per volermi bene per
riuscire a dare una risposta a questa
mia domanda e io questo modo lo trovato
attraverso la danza è stato con un
interruttore un interruttore perché
perché la prima volta che sono entrata
in una scuola o comunque messo i piedi
su una pista da ballo sono riuscita a
far scomparire
tutto quello che avevo intorno è
scomparso tutto se in quel momento io
provavo una grande rabbia nei confronti
del mondo perché comunque io entro
natale inevitabile ha gli occhi puntati
addosso è così e ve lo dico io che non
ci vedo ma me li sento addosso perché te
lo sente addosso senti il bisbiglio
senti la risatina senti tante cose
nel mio momento di danza la rabbia che
io provavo in quel momento si
trasformava in un'emozione così grande
da colpire le persone dritte al cuore
per l'energia che arrivava lì non ero
più elena travaini quella che che occhi
che sa che faccia che ama e roerina
travaini mazza guarda questa come balla
guarda come si muove wow
piano piano perché comunque si è voluto
tempo ci sono voluti veramente sacrifici
allenamento prendevo sempre più
consapevolezza di questo mio tra
virgolette potenziale di questa mia
qualità che mi permetteva di dimostrare
al mondo quello che io sono come persona
al di là del concetto diciamo su cui si
balla su cui si basa la bellezza perché
alla fine chi è che ha deciso che la
bellezza debba essere la ragazza 90 60
90 alta un metro e ottanta biondissima
con gli occhi azzurri
la bellezza apparente a me per quanto mi
riguarda il mio percorso di vita
veramente fatta soffrire ma anche fatta
crescere perché volevo dimostrare al
mondo che c'è qualcosa di in più che non
è solo quello e da una bellezza
apparente sono riuscita a passare ad una
bellezza emozionale o la bellezza che
attraverso la mia arte crea emozioni né
contro nei confronti delle persone è
stato un percorso molto introspettivo
molto bello e allo stesso tempo anche
molto difficile perché non pensate ma
per una persona che ha problemi di vista
riuscire a ballare non è proprio una
cosa subito fatta è molto semplice e
anche qui ho avuto una grande fortuna di
incontrare quello che attualmente è il
mio compagno di vita e anche il mio
ballerino anthony che durante un
percorso che abbiamo intrapreso insieme
di competizioni comunque dove hai tutta
una serie di regole ben precise dalle
quali tu non puoi sfuggire anche se sei
disabili non gli interessa niente a
nessuno quelle sono le regole
quelli sono i passi quella la precisione
e quello devi fare punto ovviamente per
me la cosa era molto complesso iniziato
comunque ad andare in crisi dicevo ma
con a cosa che amo così tanto che per me
mi fa stare bene
si inizia a trasformarsi in un emozione
negativa
sono veramente andata in crisi cioè
tornavo dalle elezioni in lacrime
fino a quando anthony ha deciso di voler
provare insieme a me un'emozione diversa
mi dice ok facciamo una cosa voglio
provare a ballare bendato con te voglio
provare a vedere se togliendo il senso
della vista
riusciamo a creare qualcosa di buono
insieme è stata un'emozione fantastica 1
perché comunque è stata la condivisione
di una situazione diversa e un grande
gesto d'amore da parte sua nei miei
confronti
2 perché in realtà anche qui è scattato
un altro interruttore cosa è successo
che ballando insieme bendati si è creato
la condivisione e una comunicazione un
feeling tra di noi
ancora più potente le mozioni
esplodevano esplodevano proprio le
persone che ci hanno visto ballare hanno
sempre ripetuto questa frase che io
adoro dicendoci voi due quando ballate
create una magia che penso che sia la
cosa più bella
ma la cosa più bella del mondo cioè
creare una magia un un'emozione così
grande che fa sognare penso che sia
veramente la più grande forma di
bellezza perché la magia crea un
emozione dentro ad ogni persona diversa
ogni persona se la vive a modo suo si
emoziona a modo suo
questa cosa ci ha fatto capire già fatto
capire che la persona diversamente abile
può fare delle cose una persona che non
ha nessun tipo di problema e si pone
nelle condizioni che non sono quelle a
cui è abituato a vivere in cui abituato
a vivere normalmente può fare può fare
anche se tu vai a cambiare una
situazione di normalità e vai a togliere
un qualcosa puoi fare
e qui cosa abbiamo deciso di fare
abbiamo deciso di portare questo
messaggio questa esperienza e proporla
alle persone noi sono ormai sette anni
che stiamo insieme sono tre anni che
abbiamo deciso di creare questo progetto
che si chiama blind di dancing che
proprio vuol dire danzare ciecamente o
ballare al buio e abbiamo toccato le
120mila persone che hanno fatto questo
tipo di esperienza con noi è una cosa
fantastica un messaggio molto potente
un'esperienza che permette alle persone
di trovare la loro bellezza trovare una
bellezza che esteriormente non
non arriverebbe mai una persona quando
si cala nel buio
ballan quindi è una condizione giocosa
gioiosa non è un discorso pesante che
stavo dicendo come in questo caso dove
ci sono io che parlo parlo parlo e voi
ascoltate
è un momento molto più interattivo ma
soprattutto è un momento in cui bisogna
imparare a fidarsi di se stessi e ad
affidarsi completamente un'altra persona
è veramente difficile
e difficile calarsi nel buio perché
calarsi nel buio vuol dire imparare a
superare dei limiti imparare a superare
dei limiti mettersi in gioco
ma la soddisfazione più grande di tutte
è quando chi fa questo tipo di
esperienza arriva alla fine rendendosi
conto di aver cambiato qualcosa dentro
di sé il fatto di calarsi nel buio di
farsi portare da un'altra persona di
affidare le proprie emozioni le proprie
paure ad un'altra persona spesso e
volentieri anche uno sconosciuto perché
noi mischiamo le persone cioè facciamo
proprio interagire ed è un qualcosa che
dentro ti fa cambiare il modo di
ragionare diventi più forte hai voglia
di metterti in gioco in maniera diversa
su tutti i vari problemi che si possono
che si possono presentare nel corso
della vita
e questa è un
il terzo tipo di bellezza secondo me
quello che più mi appartiene
sono passata da una bellezza apparente
che è una bellezza che mi ha fatto
soffrire mi ha fatta crescere
ho trovato la mia bellezza che è una
bellezza emozionale che mi permette
attraverso la danza di riuscire a stare
bene io di volermi bene io e volendo mi
bene io riuscire ad essere una buona
persona anche nei confronti e nei
rapporti con gli altri e poi ho scoperto
la mia di bellezza la risposta a tutte
le domande
una bellezza unica perché io sono una
persona unica porto in viso i segni di
una malattia porto il viso i segni di
mesi anni tre anni di chemioterapia
laserterapia radioterapia operazioni
eccetera eccetera eccetera
tante domande tante sofferenze però sono
qui sono la bellezza unica o una storia
da raccontare ho raggiunto i miei
obiettivi li ho fatti con centinaia di
migliaia di persone e quello che a me
piace del lavoro che faccio
al di là della danza in sé è riuscire ad
aiutare le altre persone a trovare la
loro di bellezza quella bellezza
interiore che ci fa sognare quella
bellezza interiore che ci permette di
sentirci persone complete di dire si
anche io ce la posso fare io ce la
faccio perché nessuno al mondo può dirci
che non possiamo fare qualcosa
noi possiamo fare tutto quello che
vogliamo
i limiti è una sola semplice concezione
mentale ce li poniamo da soli limiti ma
se noi non sogniamo non viviamo e non
c'è niente di più bello al mondo che
avere un grande sogno ea piccoli piccoli
passi riuscire a raggiungere questo
grande sogno voi che siete un pubblico
meraviglioso siete il mio grande sogno
raggiunto l'ennesimo passo avanti
nell'obiettivo della mia vita nel
portare un messaggio nel riuscire a
farvi uscire da questa sala pensando e
avendo un concetto di bellezza diverso
da quello con il quale siete entrati qui
dentro
io sono un amante tra l'altro della moda
quindi pensate quanto è stato difficile
per me riuscire ad entrare in un mondo
dove tutto è standardizzato dove tutto
ha inquadrato
eppure ce l'ho fatta perché per fortuna
ci sono persone che sognano persone che
hanno la mente aperta quindi molto open
mind persone che hanno deciso attraverso
la mia figura la mia persona di non
rappresentare la classica modella ma di
far indossare un abito a una donna che
ha qualcosa da raccontare dare un
significato anche alla creazione di
altri artisti raccontare una storia una
storia potente una storia ricca di
emozione una storia ricca di bellezza
perché la bellezza signore ce l'abbiamo
dentro ognuno di noi è bello ed è bello
a modo suo e se ve lo dico io
fidatevi è vero perché
e veramente difficile riuscire a vivere
in un mondo dove ti senti ogni giorno
giudicato e allora io voglio che le
persone mi giudichino mi metto su un
palco e racconto la mia storia perché se
mi dovete giudicare lo dovete fare per
la persona che sono e per la storia che
ho da raccontarvi e non solo per il mio
aspetto questo per farvi ragionare su
come ognuno di noi ha il diritto e il
dovere di volersi bene sentirsi bello e
amarsi perché soltanto in questo modo
possiamo vedere il bello
nelle altre persone
[Musica]
[Applauso]